[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 6 juin bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
vingt mille voyageurs l'empruntent
chaque jour la gare sncf de la verrière
va subir un important lifting à partir
de l'année prochaine est les travaux
suscitent des inquiétudes sur
l'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite
plusieurs élus réclament qu'un ascenseur
soit ajouté au programme du chantier et
jusqu'au 8 juin c'est la semaine
nationale de la prévention du diabète
sept cent mille français vivent
aujourd'hui avec la pathologie sans le
savoir dans le département l'association
des diabétiques des yvelines est
mobilisée nous recevons l'un de ses
membres georges courtial et puis comme
chaque année le réseau entreprendre
yvelines remet ses prix hier 16
personnes ont été distinguées à
versailles à l'occasion de la fête des
lauréats invité de ce journal également
marqué mais ce président du happy hours
business club le club d'affaires saint
quentinois fête ses 5 ans une soirée
d'anniversaire au programme mardi
prochain elle met d'abord direction
clairefontaine en yvelines accusé de
l'équipe de france de football nicolas
landry bonsoir vous êtes sur place et
vous allez assister dans quelques
minutes à la dernière séance des bleus à
clairefontaine qui est ouverte au public
et ce avant mondial avant le mondial
puisque nicolas la coupe du monde en
russie c'est dans huit jours
effectivement grégory les joueurs de
l'équipe de france vont arriver d'ici
quelques minutes pour travailler et
d'arrache-pied pour préparer et faire
dernier les derniers préparatifs pour
cette coupe du monde deux en russie et
je suis avec hubert l'un des supporters
présents pour ce dernier entraînement
hubert qui est un qui est supporters de
longue date de l'équipe de france a de
bien sûr c'est surtout je suis à le des
manolo de l'équipe de france et avec le
coq je vous le présente
on a déjà voyagé à ses dents tout
monde avec fougue faire gagner l'équipe
de france alors justement cette équipe
de france vous la sentez comment là
quelques jours du début du mondial
mais enfin quand l'équipe de france pour
moi avec notre entraîneur déjà la
pression va venir là les matches de
poule
mon prono sait que les matches de poule
contre l'australie c'est un match un peu
plus facile mais après il ya le père ou
le danemark et et après pour entrer
vraiment dans le vif du sujet c'est que
dans il manque un un bon meneur d'hommes
comment dire d'accord la crise mais on a
des bons buteurs mais on veut on veut
les voir les dans les mac est très très
important parce que là on passe du 8e de
finale et les quarts de finale là il
faut vraiment avoir de le dynamique et
être rentré dans le stade et je souhaite
pas ou si c'est quelqu'un que je ne
souhaite jamais avoir des grands joueurs
pendant une grande coupe du monde et on
voit des joueurs blessés
parce qu'après ça s'agace toute l'équipe
mais il faut dire que pour gagner il
faut dans mon objectif comme didier
deschamps en match après match gagné
prendre match après match ne pas dire
voit plus au plus haut point de
l'australie prend le pérou promenade ma
attend de l'équipe qui va rencontrer en
huitièmes de finale
ensuite passé le quart match après match
et vous serez présent russie pour
encourager l'équipe de france on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup de supporters déjà
pour les entraînements là est ce que
vous serez en russie sur un but de
lecointe ses obligés d d'ailleurs aussi
parce que je n'ai pas posé à lormont
d'aller au musée du club de mon petit
club et c'est que s'ils ne va pas c'est
que concentre à palamos faire mais
surtout comme je vous présente mon asile
à 2 pour la russie il faut avoir ce the
ivy pourquoi accéder en russie une
dernière question qu'elle commet
comment vous sentez l'engouement qu'il
ya autour de cette équipe de france est
ce qu'on peut la comparer l'engouement à
ses petits amis en 1998 non on ne peut
pas comparer à 2,98 et celle de
2018 on ne peut pas comparer parce que
pour gagner la coupe du monde en 98 mois
il ya un truc qui nous a fait du bien
pour du mal c'est que l'équipe qui nous
a fait du bien c'est que vu qu'on
n'était pas on était favoris on n'était
pas été qualifié pendant la coupe du
monde
en bon américain mesa en fin de compte
ça a donné du baume à l'équipe de
l'enthousiasmé du moins il ya eu lieu
dans notre pays en france et bien fait
on a bien fait on a gagné
félicitations à toute l'équipe on a
gagné mais il ya des matches qui m'ont
fait vraiment très très peur je suis la
mère alors en espérant en espérant que
cette fois ci l'équipe de france ne vous
tombera pas dans ce même fera pas les
mêmes erreurs et du coup 10 parts et
voilà depuis trois jours ils se
mobilisent devant la gare de la verrière
les élus de la commune et du
mesnil-saint-denis feront signer une
pétition leur revendication est la
construction d'un ascenseur pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite à la gare
côté la verrière il ne figure pas dans
le programme des travaux qui vont
concerner le site l'an prochain les
explications de nicolas landry plus de
600 signatures en trois jours pour la
pétition intitulée égalité d'accès à la
gare de la verrière une égalité demandé
par les élus de la commune et du
mesnil-saint-denis la construction des
ascenseurs et déjà prévu du côté de
maurepas et sur les deux quais de la
gare du côté de la verrière
l'installation de cet équipement n'est
pas assurée un investissement de plus
d'un million d'euros par ascenseur
comme tout le monde est à peu près
d'accord que il faut d ascenseur pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite le
problème il est financier la sncf elle
elle voit
l'entretien que leur apporter
au niveau des ascenseurs donc
je peux comprendre mais en même temps
nous de ce côté là on a un vrai besoin
le mesnil saint denis est aussi
concernée selon la mairie près de 3000
habitants de la commune sont
susceptibles de fréquenter la gare de la
verrière des usagers qui viennent aussi
de la vallée de chevreuse prendre ce
train à descendre avec une valise ou
bien avec une poussette et des enfants
eh ben ça alors ça relève de l'exploit
donc il est absolument anormal que
aujourd'hui à notre époque faire une
rénovation de gares sans prévoir la mise
en accessibilité pour une grande partie
de la population puisque je pense que
les flux de ce côté dépasse les deux
tiers des usagers de la garde
bah tout simplement c'est pas normal
selon saint quentin en yvelines
l'installation de cet ascenseur devrait
être portée par la sncf une version que
conteste l'entreprise ferroviaire en
attente de nouvelles informations sur le
financement
ces travaux s'inscrivent dans la
rénovation du pôle gare de la verrière
un investissement global des
collectivités de 16 millions d'euros
des travaux prévus entre 2019 et 2022 à
maurepas les professeurs et élèves du
lycée 17 mars sont en colère ils se sont
réunis hier mardi devant leur
établissement pour protester contre la
suppression de l'option sport à la
rentrée 2010 neuf une mesure de
l'éducation nationale effective à partir
de la rentrée 2010 neuf et qui concerne
120 lycées en france 3 dans l'académie
de versailles reportage de michael et
demi d'euros ces professeurs de paix s
du lycée 17 mar joue peut être le match
le plus important de leur carrière
brassard noir autour du bras ils ont
organisé ce mardi 5 juin une veillée
funèbre
objectif protester contre la suppression
de l'option sport dans leur
établissement leur rentrée 2010 9 voulue
par l'éducation nationale on pouvait pas
se permettre de rien faire parce qu'on
pense à nos élèves on pense aussi à
notre équipe de direction qui nous a
toujours soutenus au niveau du projet
d'établissement
on pense à tous et on pense à on pense à
tous les parents qui sont aussi investir
la spécialité instauré depuis 1999 par
l'établissement permet aux élèves
d'ajouter cinq heures de sport en plus
par semaine en second des quatre en
première et en terminale
cette année près d'une centaine d'élèves
ont choisi cette option donc un vrai
gâchis parce que je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient mesure est un petit peu là
la perte
la perte et l'expérience que ça peut
apporter aussi bien pour accéder à une
filière staps pour les élèves qui
sortent avec le bac ou pour des
simplement pour leur épanouissement
personnel l'enrichissement pour pour le
bac pour les points que ça peut apporter
au bac
d'autres actions pourraient être menées
dans les prochaines semaines le match
n'est peut-être pas encore terminée
jusqu'à vendredi c'est la semaine
nationale de la prévention du diabète en
france la pathologie touche 3 millions
et demi de personnes soit 5% de la
population et des associations de
passion existe pour mener des actions de
prévention d'information et
d'accompagnement bonsoir georges
courtial vous êtes membre justement
l'une de ces associations représentant
de l'afd 78 c'est l'association des
diabétiques des yvelines vous êtes vous
même atteint de diabète depuis plus de
40 ans alors un point d'information déjà
pour pour nos téléspectateurs le diabète
se caractérise par un excès de sucre
dans le sang
comment on explique la présence en excès
de ce sucre dans le fond ça serait très
haut vous expliquer je vais essayer de
faire court il y a deux types de diabète
le diabète de type 1 c'est dans ce cas
de deux types
le pancréas ne fonctionne plus du tout
d'accord dont il ne libère plus
d'insuline et il ya un diabète de type 2
qui est différent où le pancréas
fonctionne encore mais fonctionne mal
pas suffisamment ou mal et je veux il ya
des facteurs à risque peut-être des
comportements qui qui qui arrive au
diabète justement qui mène au diabète
alors dans le cas du diabète de type 1
malgré toutes les recherches
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas quelle est
l'origine exacte d'accord le diabète de
type 2 alors il faut dire que le diabète
de type 2 c'est quand même celui qui
représente le plus de cap est fixé à 90%
la population à 10 % des diabétiques et
dans ce type de diabète là les facteurs
qui contribuent à voir ce diabète sont
d'origine hygiéno diététiques
donc ça va être le comportement
diététique que l'on va avoir peut-être
la consommation d'aliments sucrés
voilà ce diamètre il apparaît souvent
dans des personnes de plus de 50 ans le
plus souvent aussi mais pas toujours et
les personnes obèses et ou qui ont eu
dix ans qui ne veut qu'ils n'ont pas une
alimentation bien équilibrée et qui qui
est aussi souffre un peu trop de
sédentarité
c'est souvent le gros problème ça veut
dire quoi aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
on peut penser qu'il y aura plus de
personnes personnes diabète dans dans
vingt voire trente ans que les
populations sont plus en plus sédentaire
on peut imaginer que le chiffre le
nombre de diabétiques va évoluer
oui alors il ya des projections qui sont
faites dans ce temps vont dans ce sens
là
mais quelquefois
elles n'aboutissent pas aux résultats
prévus parce que de par chance quand
même maintenant il ya beaucoup
d'information sur le diabète
on a un système de santé quand même qui
est où malgré les critiques que les gens
peuvent faire est de bonne qualité et
des associations telles que la volt sont
sont présentes pour pour informer qu'à
l'action mettre en place par exemple
lèvres des 78 quels types d'actions
alors la hutte et soixante dix huit
joueuses je vous dirai ça se résume en
fait en trois mots clés la prévention
l'information et l'accompagnement
d'accord alors se veut dans le domaine
de la prévention
nous pratiquons des dépistages
glycémique
c'est une opération de prélèvement au
bout du doigt d'une goutte de sang bon
c'est très rapide et c'est quand même
très significatif est alors dans le dans
le domaine maintenant de
l'accompagnement nous faisons des
permanences on va permettre par exemple
vous voyez je viens de terminer une
permanence aux clayes-sous-bois nous
recevons des patients diabétiques ou des
parents de patients diabétiques
accompagné aussi pour aider peut-être
ses patients à mieux vivre avec leur
diabète pour mieux vivre au quotidien
leur diabète etc souvent utile aussi de
rencontrer justement les
la famille le conjoint souvent parce que
c'est difficile à vivre aussi pour le
conjuration cette maladie donc
accompagnement est normal qu'une minute
et l'oncle le dernier c'est
l'information dernière mission c'est ça
de cette association
voilà l'information donc où participait
souvent des forums santé l'un des villes
des yvelines alors je vais vous dire
quand même un mot à propos de notre
association c'est très important
elle sait que nous avons été obligés de
restreindre notre domaine d'action
nous sommes avec les 60 18 78 ça
voudrait dire tout le département des
yvelines
en réalité nous a été obligé de réduire
nous nous contentons maintenant de de la
base simple restreint un bassin de plus
restreint
c'est la communauté de communes de saint
quentin en yvelines communauté
d'agglomération est d'ailleurs retrouver
pour tous les habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines et ses alentours on peut
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site internet de la fdj 78 qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran voilà pour plus
d'information merci georges courtial je
suis né mais c'est moi l'entraîneur est
rapidement allé parce que c'est très
très salée à temps nous sommes
actuellement vraiment en période de
difficile par manque de bénévoles
notre présidente va bientôt nous
abandonner parce que des raisons
personnelles et il serait très important
que lang recueille j'espère que par oui
les jours de d'avoir de nouvelles forces
est peut-être en tout cas le site
internet et est affichée souhaite le
contact avec vous parce que il en va il
omet vous demander de la pérennité de
l'association
si vous voulez aujourd'hui nous avons un
bilan financier qui est très bon mais
c'est le problème on l'a compris le
problème aujourd'hui c'est de trouver
ses bénévoles ses bénévoles merci
georges courtial d'avoir été avec le jeu
rappelle que vous êtes membre de cette
association l'afd 78 qui accompagne
notamment les patients malades du
diabète
ils sont merci à vous ils sont seize 16
nouveaux entrepreneurs récompensé hier
mardi par le réseau entreprendre
yvelines et des créations ou des
reprises de sociétés
toutes ont permis de maintenir l'emploi
sur le territoire avec camille lambert
était à la fête des lauréats au palais
des congrès de versailles regardez vous
verrez le monde en changeant de
boulangerie cette phrase c'est la devise
de thomas journel qui lui a valu la
création de sa boulangerie à versailles
en septembre 2010 est du pain bio mais
aussi un lieu de partage avec des cours
de yoga et des expositions culturelles à
le ou vers un lieu international un lieu
polyvalent un lieu où on fait des
rencontres où on peut se retrouver à
n'importe quelle heure avec des
activités adaptées par rapport à ce
qu'on vient chercher dans le matin il ya
un petit déj
le midi un plat du jour le soir veut
boire un verre un concept qui a séduit
le réseau entreprendre yvelines
thomas journel fait partie des nouveaux
entrepreneurs de la promotion 2010 est
les seize lauréats ont été récompensés
par l'association au palais des congrès
de versailles
il ya une aide financière nos lauréats
perçoivent environ trente quarante mille
euros d aides financières qui vont
surtout leur permettre d'avoir un effet
de levier vis-à-vis de nos banques
partenaires
ce qui est très très important c'est
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement qui
est lyon mis en place avec un chef
d'entreprise en activité la plupart du
temps qui va suivre le lauréat pendant à
peu près deux années une assistance pour
concrétiser son projet avec ce
dispositif longue liew a pu créer sa
marque de souliers en mars et voit déjà
plus loin
notre rêve c'était de faire des souliers
à la main par du pas des souris à la
main comme comme on faisait il ya
plusieurs siècles on peut grandir avant
avant avant 3 ans 3 d'ici 3 à 5 ans
compte est grossir l'équipe est embauché
3 à 5 personnes
seul ombre au tableau soulevées par la
vice-présidente de la région et marraine
de la promotion alexandra dublanche
encore trop peu de femmes font partie de
l' aventure surtout les entrepreneurs
qui sont accompagnés par des structures
comme réseau entreprendre et à 39 % de
femmes nous logiquement on veut
atteindre 50% de femmes et c'est
l'objectif toutes ces structures les
finances on leur a dit maintenant on
vous met cet objectif 50 % depuis ses
débuts en 2011 réseau entreprendre
yvelines a perdu de crimes de sauvegarde
et 1400 emplois sur le territoire
on continue de parler économie dans ce
journal avec un nouvel invité marc tms
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'happy hour business comme c'est un
club de d'affaires qui est basée à saint
quentin en yvelines il fête ses cinq ans
cette année donc la soirée
d'anniversaire ça sera le 12 juin à
lille de loisirs saint quentin en
yvelines
on va en parler dans un instant
déjà en revenons aux prémices de ce club
pourquoi le fondée en 2013 dans un
territoire où il ya saisi l'entreprise
un territoire riche d'entreprise votre
argument il a déjà un peu de la réponse
il faut savoir que moi j'ai un passé
j'ai été pendant 38 ans et demi de
salariés au groupe malakoff médéric et
je m'occupais des entreprises et j'ai
été chargé des relations extérieures
donc je suis parti en retraite au 1er
mars 2013
et comme pour moi la retraite n'est pas
une fin en soi mais un début d'une
aventure j'ai tout de suite créé une
société c'est pas une association c'est
une société
et puis je me suis posé la question tout
tout on était qu'est ce que je sais
faire ça a été vite fait faire du
relationnel et mettre en relation les
entreprises les unes des autres
c'était mon job et gd ce qui le
différencie des autres clubs d'affaires
ce qu'il y en a plusieurs sens très
justement il fallait absolument que je
sois différent des autres cités pour
créer un énième club d'affaires je
l'aurais pas fait donc j'ai basé le club
d'affaires sur la culture
comment ça marche le deuxième mardi de
chaque mois à l'ugc qui est un de mes
partenaires dans une salle de cinéma
j'organise des conférences avec des
sujets très
varié il ya eu une conférence récemment
sur la sorcellerie la route saint
jacques de compostelle justement le set
là c'est à dire demain
j'ai une conférence une deuxième sur en
route pour saint jacques de compostelle
pour la petite histoire les conférences
je suis complet jusqu'en juin 2019
c'est de ces faits dont créé en
septembre jouent le jeu la donne en
avant première la conférence va
s'appeler j'en parlerai à mon cheval
c'est original
en fait j'ai dans mes entreprises
quelqu'un qui fait de l'écrit
communication c'est une formation avec
les chevaux il va nous expliquer un
petit peu comment ça fonctionne et
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la relation
entre le cheval et l'humain quelque
chose qu'on a pu voir par exemple dans
un film comme l'homme qui murmurait à
l'oreille des 5 ans quelles évolutions
vous avez pu noter que ted en termes de
membres est ce que vous avez grandi en
termes de manque un petit peu comme un
petit peu quand j'ai démarré en juin
on était une quarantaine de culte est
déjà pas mal pendant départ j'ai cent
dix-sept sociétés adhérentes à ce jour à
jour de cotisation et j'ai à peu près
400 sociétés qui gravitent autour
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être adhérent
pour venir aux conférences et donc il y
en a qui viennent à la séance qui
choisissent leur lancée voilà et qui
payent leurs séances et puis je leur
enlever le soir même une facture et le
fait de se rencontrer au sein de ces
conférences qui sont un peu informés
puisque c'est pas vraiment autour du
thème mais derrière ya toujours un
cocktail champagnisé et ça favorise
forcément les échanges
c'est évident c'est un vrai club d'en
faire un petit peu business j'insiste
bien c'est convivialité business culture
sur l'anniversaire donc on line l'happy
hour 5e dont un à lille de l'an prochain
mardi prochain à partir de 18 heures
adultes de loisirs on avait été un
terrain complètement les anniversaires
c'est toujours festif chez moi on fait
la fête
mais toujours il n'ya pas de parti pris
et pas deux
ça se passe normalement très bien un
cocktail j'ai même la chance cette année
d'avoir un quatuor de saxophones de
l'université de saint quentin qui
viennent des partenaires il faut savoir
que dans mes partenaires mais il y en a
des prestigieux ted et fils notamment
enfin tv soixante dix huit depuis le 1er
juillet les narguer oui mais moi ça fait
longtemps
et puis ben j'ai lu j'ai c'est bien sûr
j'ai eu le théâtre de saint quentin j'ai
le golf national
j'ai le vélodrome et pour la soirée
l'université du 12 plusieurs animations
notamment de l'agility golf pilotage de
drones exactement les gens qui vont
venir ils pourront faire en volonté ce
qu'ils veulent conduire des drones se
tenir en équilibre dans les grosses
bulles sur l'eau faire du site ikoko une
espèce de cartes sur un circuit pas
possible s'initier à l'adresse au niveau
du golfe
enfin etc etc surprise sur il nous reste
20 secondes qu'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter pour vos cinq ans ou à pied
avant qu'on se retrouve l'année
prochaine pour les 6 ans et que ça
continue de pousser puisque je joue les
dj 117 aujourd'hui sociétés adhérentes
et puis bon je petite particularité
je ne fais pas de prospection jamais
depuis cinq ans ce sont les adhérents
qui m'emmène des membres et je peux vous
assurer que c'est la meilleure des
politiques et pour participer à cette
soirée conçoit des rangs ou non
adhérents alors il ya brésil possibilité
si si les gens ça les intéresse
eh ben je le retourne par retour de mail
gmail c'est ms points marque arbas
gmail.com
je leur retour de l'invitation s'affiche
alors c'est super sympa et puis voilà et
et ça me fera un grand plaisir qu'on
soit 120 ou qu'on soit 130 ou 140 ça
changera pas la face du monde de toute
façon j'ai déjà plus de 110 réservation
merci marquer mais avec le président du
happy hours business club et ont rappelé
que ce club d'affaires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fête cette
année ses 50 ans d'humour avant de
refermer ce journal quelques chose de
festif également les vacances d'été
approchent à grands pas et les apéritifs
vont se multiplier alors pourquoi pas le
faire autour de charcuteries son
invention pourrait elle vous simplifier
la vie et elika lindemann a conçu une
trancheuse à saucisson cet habitant de
méré a reçu la médaille d'argent du
dernier concours lépine à la foire de
paris là patrick jacques de dixmude et
clémence derniers l'ont rencontré
tranche fine ou épaisse
cette machine va enfin couper court au
débat l'yvelinois eric lindeman est
l'inventeur de cette tranche est
associée sont revisités plus fonctionnel
et 100% française l'idée lui est venue
devant sa télévision
j'ai été séduit par ce produit est tout
de suite je me suis dit il fallait
vraiment que je crée un modèle avec une
inclinaison à 45° l'idée c'est vraiment
de créer quelque chose à 45° qui puisse
aider couper facilement et surtout tous
les aliments parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les démons faire
simplement une trancheuse associés sont
en faire une deuxième nom mais l'idée
c'était vraiment de pouvoir développer
un produit qui soit vraiment utile au
quotidien
eric dit s'être inspiré de la guillotine
mais cette tranche s'avère beaucoup plus
convivial puisqu'elle coupe aussi les
carottes tomates citron et même les
pommes de terre
cette invention a connu un succès
tranchant auprès du jury du concours
lépine qui lui a décerné la médaille
d'argent alors que ce qu'on ressent
quand on sort ce diplôme
on est plutôt content et satisfait on se
dit c'est c
c'est une belle réussite et c'est très
valorisant et c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de commentaires très positifs
de personnes qui m'ont félicité je
pensais pas que l'impact serait aussi
important finalement son originalité
chaque modèle est fabriqué totalement à
la main deux entreprises du territoire
sont sollicités pour sa création une
pour le bois et l'autre pour la lame le
côté eric commercialise ces machines au
prix de 89 euros
c'est la fin de ce journal à suivre le
7-8 culture présentée par mélanie poquet
et les reportages de cette édition sont
à revoir sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv et 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]